"The Santa Clause" came out back in 1994, so
while no one from the cast actually became Santa,
they have definitely aged. Keep watching for
how the cast of this holiday classic looks now.
At the time The Santa Clause was released,
Tim Allen was already an established star in
the realms of stand-up comedy and sitcoms,
thanks to his hit series Home Improvement.
Playing Scott Calvin quickly made him a
film star, something that was cemented
just a year later by his voice role as Buzz
Lightyear in Pixar's debut feature, Toy Story.
“To infinity and beyond!”
The Santa Clause kicked off a string
of comedy films for Allen throughout
the 1990s and early 2000s, including Jungle 2
Jungle, For Richer or Poorer, and Galaxy Quest.
After Home Improvement ended in 1999 he continued
acting in films — including the two Santa Clause
sequels in 2002 and 2006 — until his return to
sitcom stardom in 2011 with Last Man Standing.
Allen continues to play his signature role of the
lovably in-over-his-head dad as he nears three
decades of acting work, and after six seasons
on ABC, Last Man Standing has a new home at FOX
as of the fall of 2018. He also went on to voice
Buzz Lightyear in all four of the Toy Story films.
Charlie Calvin is an eager young man whose
only wish is to get right to work helping
his father be the best Santa he can
be. This includes even going as far
as journeying to the North Pole to help
the elves design and build a new sleigh.
Eric Lloyd, who played Charlie, shared a
similar work ethic throughout the 1990s.
Though he's best known for his role in
The Santa Clause and its two sequels,
Lloyd has plenty of other acting credits to
his name dating back to age two. Back then,
he appeared as young Kevin on The Wonder Years.
After The Santa Clause came along and made him
even more visible, he continued to work steadily
for the rest of the decade, playing a young Bruce
Wayne in Batman & Robin, and landing a recurring
role on the Christina Applegate-led sitcom Jesse.
These days, Lloyd spends much of his time
behind the camera. After graduating from
Chapman University with a degree in film
production, he co-founded LP Studios,
a production and post-production company
for the film and music industries.
His work includes everything from
sound mixing to cinematography.
David Krumholtz's screen acting career was just
beginning when he landed the role of Bernard.
He’s the grumpy but ultimately compassionate head
elf who guides Scott and Charlie through their
North Pole journey and ultimately provides a way
for the father and son to stay in contact at the
end of the film. Krumholtz's acting career gained
considerable steam throughout the 1990s and 2000s,
so much so that while he reprised
his role for The Santa Clause 2,
he was unable to return for The Santa Clause 3:
The Escape Clause because of another commitment.
“Where’d he go?”
That commitment was Krumholtz's other best-known
role: mathematician Charlie Eppes on the hit CBS
drama Numb3rs, a role he played for five years
and nearly 120 episodes. To this day Krumholtz
continues to work regularly in both film and
television, more recently appearing in the
TV series Living Biblically and The Deuce,
and films like The Ballad of Buster Scruggs.
An acclaimed talent in the United
States as well as her native Canada,
Wendy Crewson worked regularly throughout
the 1980s in film and television. Then,
she landed the role of Laura Miller in The
Santa Clause. Like her frequent scene partner
Judge Reinhold, she grew from non-believer
to supporter and ally in Scott Calvin's
Santa adventures. And the film's popularity
allowed her to return for both of its sequels.
Crewson also continued to work
regularly after The Santa Clause,
and gained higher-profile roles in American
film and television because of it. Among her
other major credits after the film are
Air Force One, starring Harrison Ford,
and the Canadian supernatural medical drama
Saving Hope, in which she co-starred for five
seasons between 2012 and 2017. In 2016, the
Canadian Screen Awards presented her with its
Earle Grey Award, recognizing her lifetime
of contributions to television in Canada.
Judge Reinhold was already an established name
as an actor by the time The Santa Clause was
made. But unlike Tim Allen — who was on the
rise — Reinhold had already faced a decade
of ups and downs in the film industry.
After hits like Beverly Hills Cop and
Fast Times at Ridgemont High, he'd also
dealt with major flops like Vice Versa,
and had retreated back into supporting roles. The
Santa Clause introduced him to a new audience,
and as Dr. Neil Miller he was beloved and
brought back for both of the film's sequels.
Since The Santa Clause Reinhold has also
continued to work steadily in film and television,
including appearing in the series Arrested
Development and the 2017 film Bad Grandmas,
as well as many other guest star appearances.
Like Allen, Lloyd, Crewson, and Reinhold, Peter
Boyle also has the distinction of appearing in
all three films in the Santa Clause trilogy,
but unlike them, he played different roles.
Boyle — whose film acting career was already
well-established and nearly three decades old
at the time of the original film — played
Scott's boss Mr. Whittle in the first film.
He was then brought back to play Father Time in
both The Santa Clause 2 and The Santa Clause 3.
Boyle's career before The Santa
Clause was already well-established,
and included celebrated roles in everything
from Young Frankenstein to Taxi Driver,
but it was what happened after the first film
was released that made him a household name.
Boyle was cast as Frank Barone on the massively
successful sitcom Everybody Loves Raymond,
for which he received seven consecutive Emmy Award
nominations for Outstanding Supporting Actor in
a Comedy Series. Unfortunately, Boyle passed
away on December 12, 2006, at the age of 71.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite celebrities are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.